peu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo parce que tu as parce que vous
n'avez pas bougé par le single mais j'ai
bougé les yeux normalement on doit même
pas qu'il y ait des cieux non mais moi
j'ai bougé les yeux en rythme de haut en
bas de gauche à droite tout le temps
mais je vous ai pas vus ben voilà c'est
ça la force de la révolte des rebelles
bien qu'un clic il m'a pas vu quoi on va
vous faire une interview mensonge rires
ouais quand vous allez mentir il faut
que je mange oui pourquoi pas parce que
c'est une interview mensonge un bon ça
va être dur pour vous non bien on va
voir je sais pas j'ai déjà menti aussi
c'est vrai que vous avez une fortune en
fait est que vous avez beaucoup de
beaucoup d'argent qui est placé en
action son marché international alors
qu'est ce qu'il faut dire est ce que tu
as déjà des malades et nous la vérité
déjà des géants que dira si vous êtes
bourrés de blaye away est ce que est ce
que vous ban avait toujours en limousine
vitres fumées ou fait allumer vos clubs
par vos assistants
ah oui bah ça évidemment oui
et j'ai quand on fait ça aux hommes
politiques n'y a pas de problème est
qu'on ferait tout de suite et qu'on fait
ça avec un artiste c'est plus compliqué
oui il est toujours inscrit à l'udf
c'est quoi lui dave l'union l'union des
mouvements tels des fromagers évidemment
ouais bien sûr l'idée c'est vrai j'ai
acquis cela que j'avais été obligé
d'arrêter de fumer des pétards pour
pouvoir vous inscrire à l'udf
je fume des pétards
alors arrêter à temps il ya deux
mensonges à faire un truc contrat de
quoi je vais arrêter de fumer déjà
arrêté pour me dire que non pas par
habitude et des pétards oui c'est ça oui
j arrete que l'uimm et qu'elle nous
disait il on fume cds il fume des
pétards ont fait le plein
voilà sur le plan sexuel vous souhaitez
toujours sur tout ce qui bouge
non mais oui mais oui ou non du nom du
martyr ben oui faut dire la vérité c'est
ça voudra dire que tu sortes sur tout ce
qui bouge avec les gens qui fument des
pétards le dr
le d
c'est ce que j'ai fait de fumer des
pétards pour entrer à l'edf a essayé
notation vous n'êtes quand vous faites
vos tournées en province à bout
fréquenté toujours beaucoup les boîtes
échangistes
oui eh bien tu me regarde pas tunis ap
je vais pas être mêlé à ça non mais
invitant aussi quoi le plan là parce que
qu'est-ce qu'il ya cette histoire est
cet été à saint-tropez avec la pornostar
non là tu dis non pourquoi c'est comme
ça les gens vont croire qu'on copie
ktiri nom compliqué pour lui oui
arrêt à la pornostar non oui l'argent
l'accord retrouvée morte dans une pinède
à côté de saint tropez la fille comment
les malins
vraiment un m'as vraiment un mois mais
c'est vrai qu'un manipulateur nez on l'a
retrouvée morte dans une pinède à côté
de saint-tropez pinède
dernière question jacques higelin très
très compliqué l'interview mensonge
aisément les hommes politiques ça passe
tout seul
vous avez déclaré j'aimerais mourir
comme un elvis presley c'est-à-dire
intoxiqué au médicament aux sucreries
c'est vrai ça c'est dire oui oui oui
parce que dans le jeu oui oui j'ai rêvé
ça mais c'est quand même un truc de deux
les procès staliniens ou les déchirent
côté procès qui te pousse à 28 tout ça
les à-côtés procès de moscou
il ya des finances ça c'est pour
enregistrer son service et du séduisant
ça c'est dur et glissements oui alors le
résultat de ça c'est quoi
mais si vous arrivez pas c'est un thème
je n'arrivais pas à monter
comme c'est un test un peu grossier
quand même très c'est assez lourd bah
c'est vous qu'êtes lourd là avant moi
même j'y arrivais pas adacore gros con
pour la baston à quoi je démolis
[Applaudissements]
vous savez qu'on ne bouge pas pendant le
djing
[Musique]
le tout
vous avez cligner de l'oeil raphia c'est
possible non c'est pas vous le dire il
est officiellement de boycotter ce
cérémonial stupide et injustifiée voilà
c'est ma position je les ai joués
viendrait
alors bien alors politiquement quel que
soit votre fidélité à vos engagements de
jeunesse
on vous a beaucoup vu ces derniers temps
en compagnie d'alain madelin et vous
avez déclaré d'ailleurs moi un type dans
le programme politique et d'enlever sa
cravate ça me va vous lui trouvez quoi
ahmad la ba hmad là je trouve qu'il a il
a un discours qui est particulièrement
adaptée à l'époque dans laquelle nous
vivons et je trouve qu'il ya une
modernité est une espèce de fraternité
qui émane de ce discours qui à mon sens
devrait rassembler pratiquement toutes
les couches sociales de la nation c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que je vous le voyez
le réseau nettement je le vois à juste
titre d'ailleurs candidat à la
présidence de la république et j'ai la
ferme intention
et c'est parce que magna enlever sa
cravate que vous ne portez plus de
cravate c'est une sorte de mamie c'est
une sorte de mimétisme pour vous les
meilleurs du troisième millénaire ton
admirer content l'estiment quelqu'un
dont on a envie de lui ressembler c'est
un peu comme pour vous tirez vous aimez
bien vous vous êtes mis au sport fait du
vélo avec drucker
tous les dimanches matins avec michel
drucker s'espacent commencer ça ça se
passe pas bien pour lui parce qu'il a un
mal de chien à me suis pas très
entraînés ça fait des années et des
années que je [ __ ] mais sont des
termes d'ailleurs et lui pour le moment
ils pédalent plutôt dans la choucroute
c'est à dire que il nous est arrivé
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas très longtemps
d'être filmé par ses petits copains de
la 2è et c'était très emmerdant parce
que j'étais obligé de j'étais obligé de
pédaler dans le vide pour qu'il puisse
me rattrape at il tort beaucoup il dort
énormément il s'économise énormément
je ne sais pas il ya quelques jours et
quelques jurons mais peut-être que
finalement là alors il est beaucoup plus
âgée que moi à drucker donc c'est là où
au fond c'est là la différence pour le
téléthon avait fait 5 fois le tour du
périphérique en vélo 8 et admiratif x 8
x 8 x 10 7 minutes 46 secondes quatrième
est alors l'une des raisons de votre
forme c'est pierre aboutissent et que
vous avez laissé tomber la drogue d'une
façon à peu près complète sauf les
pétards mais enfin bon je vois une
dizaine de pétards par jour parce que ça
remplace ses cigarettes on va arrêter
les cigarettes donc vous êtes obligé de
fumer des pétards à la spa de pas disent
tout de même pas dire déjà bien un
parterre du périphérique voilà
et vous avez retrouvé votre légendaire
énergie sexuelle qui a fait votre succès
faut bien le dire parce qu il ya beau
talent en pierre mais ya pas que ça non
plus alors b d'ailleurs grâce à dieu il
y avait cette énergie sexuelle sinon je
serais absolument par là où je suis
aujourd'hui voilà que pierre a retrouvé
on arrête en la drogue son énergie
sexuelle on vous a beaucoup vu cet été
avec linda hardy à saint tropez
oui mais il ya d'autres corps qu'ils
avaient droit au remords il y avait
nagui avec une blonde décolorée a
déploré pierre arditi avec bolloré brute
un défi qui a démarré en tant d'amour à
mary bale donc c'est vraiment que à son
honneur la korrika durée c'est parce
qu'il va jouer si vous voulez aux tables
gymnase marie bell il y tient alors oui
mary mary bale il pas qu on sait la
petite wii mais l'aïe rappelle à l'état
mais la marie d'elle on l'applaudît
c'est joli gaston il a un autre
dinosaure il s'appelle mary bale voilà
j'ai quand on est enfant va grandir et
qui va te dire papa ya pas assez de buts
sur le plateau où tu vas faire quoi
concrètement je vais faire revenir
donc oui retournez-les en ce moment avec
joyeuses pâques en province il paraît
que c'est surtout la tournée des boîtes
échangistes
c'est à dire que si vous voulez ça fait
quand même une bonne dizaine d'années
que un peu plus même douzaine d'années
gilbert barbier m'avait dit que qu'au
fond sa clientèle son public on le
fabrique qu'en province
et j'ai suivi ce conseil à la lettre et
c'est d'ailleurs blier lui-même qui
m'avait dit que je pouvais justement en
profiter voilà l'avantagé des tournées
c'est sa fille voilà et donc ça fait une
bonne douzaine d'années maintenant que
je fais plus grands certains noms de
boîtes échangistes vous donnerai des
adresses intéressera sûrement d'accord
avec cette affaire et se connaître j'ai
l'intention d'éditer un guide
gaultmillau il ya le gardien ty guen et
jean gravity des boîtes échangistes le
hardi avec 1h heard it is the hard way
vous êtes choqué beaucoup de monde pas
mal votre mercedes vitres fumées sur la
roue et vous fait allumer des cigarettes
par les assistants pouvait pas que c'est
un peu too much
mettez vous savez moi je vais vous dire
quand on a réussi après tout c'est un
canton a du pognon
quand on a du mal et on sait bien dans
les clubs où ces maisons qu'à se
démerder pour faire les mêmes choses
voilà
on reconnait on reconnaît vraiment le
may be missed le choc
le libéral le libéral de choc alors ben
on va terminer avec la littérature fait
des lectures publiques aussi non dans
les villes où vous vous allez vous lisez
du renaud camus vous lisez du robert
brasillach du nietzsche oui bah c'est
des jeux les jeux les découvrir sur le
tard et je dois dire que j'ai eu tort
ouais c'est un manque de culture de ma
part très bons ce qui là encore il ya
une parole importante à proférer
aujourd'hui il ya une pensée que qu'on
ne partage pas suffisamment et en
particulier dans les couches basses de
la société qui ne lisent pas comme tout
le monde le sait et je voudrais être le
chantre font de cette parole vous la
tendance à atteindre et je ne vois pas
pour mes élèves voulaient vos lectures
de brasillach sont remarqués mais voilà
il antisémitisme ça vous choque plus du
tout un fût un temps où ça vous énervez
maintenant vous vivez avec ben qu'est ce
que vous voulez n'ont finalement c'est
dans l'air du temps alors après tout
pourquoi pas hein voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en le bush marketing on ne bouge pas
pendant une géniale
voilà non mais je sais mais je n'avais
pas fini ma fille tu me l'as finir
maintenant c'est pas un souci non mais
je me disais un problème de ravaillac un
ravaillac 2000 par exemple s'ils
arrivent et qui vous tuer thierry très
bien à la mer sera jamais pourquoi on ne
bouge pas laurent baffie a essayé dont
laurent gaffié notoriété lors on va
fille a fait ciller de ci de là et c est
pourquoi pour qui et on ne l'a jamais
dit pour me busch prévaloir ne saura
jamais j'emporterai de secret dans ma
tombe comme l'endroit des matchs parce
qu'on n'a qu'une vie mais moi personne
du soir non en fait je veux dire la
vérité rire il ya le secret est enfermé
dans mon coffre à la banque dans une
enveloppe scellée qu'on ouvrira à ma
mort alors une tumeur alors un message
démarquer
l'échalote 100 me en même temps c'est
pour rigoler avec le public n'obéit qu'à
moi même les maladies des vannes
criantes aussi bien alors jeté des pavés
le fait que pour énerver est ce que
c'est vrai que vos parents sont blancs
et que les votes sont noirs et ça vous
fait rigoler russe il attend du mensonge
ah oui il faut dire que ses vues faut
dire non à ces interviews mensonge c'est
à dire le contraire de la vérité
oui et vous ils sont noirs c'est évident
mais c'est ridicule est il un vrai que
lorsque alain de greef vous a vu pour la
première fois elle nous a pas reconnus
qui nous a pas reconnus côté vous avez
vu pour la première fois le seuil normal
enfin c'est pas normal
non mais je rentre chez moi par contre à
vous avez exigé quoi dans votre contrat
avec canal+ nous parce qu'on exige et
une impasse car on s'en occupe pas en
fait un tel mensonge j'ai fait le calcul
de votre bureau vous avez quoi à cames à
la tectonique des plaques c'est à dire
c'est la faille de san andreas parce que
la tectonique des plaques on n'en parle
pas assez et ça se frotte comme ça et à
la faille passe par canal exactement
tous les scores des vacances vous les
prenez au mensonge toujours bas ah ouais
ah c'est mon souhait parce que moi je
reste chez moi
le calcul fait le calcul
tous les soirs dans les arts
à 19 heures
il
comme d'entreprise de zapping
renseignez vous êtes béarnais ex
publicité avait remercié doux interview
mensonge c'est parce que tu es rebelles
qui vous pousse ça pousse à bouger par
un génial non je suis la rebelle je suis
la récalcitrante voir l'insurgé vous
êtes ultra libéral sur le plan son plan
politique le très proche de la madelin
us d'alain minc en fait oui vous vous
trouvez pas que ce système ultra libéral
est porteur de violence sociale frédéric
ah non pas du tout voulait rien un banc
le marché s'autorégule bon il ya des
licenciements massifs quand on fait des
bénéfices mais c'est très bien c'est
pour la santé des entreprises
oui beaucoup apprécié en france et je
les fais des bénéfices doit licencier
des gens en prévision du jour elle en
fera plus évidemment sinon leurs
actionnaires comment ils vivent mais il
faut je crois que c'est très important
que que les financiers puissent
s'engraisser un petit peu sur le dos de
des ouvriers non mais vous fâchent tout
ça st frédéric est ce que vous partagez
la vie de jacques séguéla qui pensent
que la pub est là pour apporter du rêve
et du bonheur aux gens
oui d'abord je rédigerai saluer
l'artiste parce que jacques séguéla
c'est un artiste c'est un poète c'est
des temps modernes et je pense que la
publicité à la porte pas seulement du
bonheur elle elle est sincère quoi ouais
comme moi en ce moment
oui bien sûr que vous aviez compris le
possible aussi que séguéla soit un
artiste je suis d'accord
alors y ait une chambre en pas à
frédéric avec vous là votre limousine
avec les vitres fumées ses assistants
qui sont toujours là pour vous allumez
les cigarettes c'est vous ça vraiment
oui parce que je pense que le pognon
c'est bien moi je trouve que je vis pour
ça et j'ai envie de voila j'ai envie
d'avoir une une existence coupé du monde
coupé de la réalité grâce des autres
bien évidemment bien sûr ça va de soi
ouais
et pourquoi avoir laissé tomber
l'ecstasy pour la cocaïne sentais que
j'avais compris chez vous ça ah non moi
en fait j'ai jamais pris ni l'un ni
l'autre
ah ouais ah non moi ça m'intéresse pas
je trouve que la drogue c'est pas bien
[Musique]
ça veut dire c'est c'est dangereux quoi
il faut jamais en prendre même un pétard
j'ai jamais fumé un pétard de ma vie
quelle est la partie de votre corps que
vous préférez frédéric m'habite
on clique et là on se connaît bien
y'a un truc qui m'a toujours surprise
chez vous c'est cette incapacité à
tromper la mère de votre enfant même
dans les situations les plus propices
aux vices finalement comment vous faites
interview mensonge là dessus ou
lalalalalala voulait vraiment coincé
non eh bien eh bien oui je la trompe
tout le temps je la trouve tout le temps
j'adore ça je pense qu'il faut se faire
sucer il faut il faut déjà que faciale
tous les soirs c'est un bout chez vous
les oreilles mahdi lesjak faciale ou
fait 80 pages là dessus sur commencer ce
billet comment remercier la bienséance
dans les actes social alors on à la
baronne vous préférez bien entendu
frédéric kadhafi gmail pour lui je sais
pas je me sentirais plus à l'aise avec
vous c'est vrai
baffie kadhafi a fait forcé
ma femme combats seules des taux des
crédits c'est bon vous plaisez à madame
de fontenay madame de reculer parce
qu'il ya un truc qui se passe c'est
marrant je sais il fit aux nobles c'est
un peu lolita à l'envers c'est bon
frédéric alors comment expliquer ce
dégoût des boîtes échangistes kivu qui
ont détesté ça moi je trouve ça honteux
ces gens qui qui qui veulent se met nu
devant d'autres personnes s'entassent et
comme ça me dégoûte
ça me dégoûte je trouve que tu as sont
globalement le sexe me dégoûte voilà ça
intéressant moi je hais les vacances en
thaïlande vous avez uniquement pour
écrire vous seulement alors c'est vrai
ouais budget de développement économique
du pays enfin votre de votre discours
est très sociable mais c'est pour écrire
oui oui et aussi manger démangeait de m
cette recherche de sainteté que selon
vous ça vient d'où
ça vient d'eux
du pape je crois que le pape c'est un
mec super il va être content mais ce que
ces matériaux mensonge donc il est
perturbé est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec elie wiesel quand tu dis beigbeder
c'est un mec bien
oui mais il pas le seul à le dire je
vous dis galles dalaï lama il ya nelson
mandela nelson mandela il a dit si
l'humanité était composé de beigbeder le
monde serait meilleur
annoncé par vaclav havel qui a dit ça
aussi je dînais avec kofi annan et
boutros boutros ghali et ils me disent
frédéric ce que vous faites pour pour
l'humanité nous fait chier à l'est de
bonheur et moi je
les comme vous êtes un mec honnête très
très honnête
un look à ce que le provincial pas
showbiz du tout je vais vous faire une
interview mensonge quand le cauchemar
d'un meeting
génial c'est bien je n'ai pas bougé
c'est parfait vous voulez toujours en
limousine avec les vitres fumées
oui j'adore ça les matins quand
j'accompagne mes enfants à l'école
j'aime bien arriver dans l'école et
c'est vrai que les états aient beaucoup
ça c'est vrai c'est une on aime bien
voir les acteurs de cinéma reid en
limousine
vous avez des assistants qui vous
allumez vos cigarettes sur les plateaux
coup j'en ai beaucoup je change souvent
est-ce que non mais c'est vrai c'est
difficile de supporter de la vie
quotidienne d'un acteur donc bien il
faut pas s'emmerder exigèrent tous les
jours assistant un des assistants
préfère oui oui oui on vous a beaucoup
vu à saint tropez cet été avec arthur
avec carlos avec collaro et là avec
nagui passer l'été avec eux oui vous
avez déclaré en parlant de ses vacances
là enfin je revis mais vouloir trouver
quoi c'est à dire que ils ont ils ont
des bateaux énorme et ça ça m'a permis
grâce à eux d'éviter loana
moi j'aime beaucoup donc il ya longtemps
que vous avez arrêté l'héroïne la
cocaïne plusieurs années non à ibos est
au courant ouais
quelquefois c'est vrai ah ouais
aujourd'hui fumer quand même pétards par
jour bah ça dépend pour l'émission l'a
pas beaucoup pas beaucoup mais on
voulait un parce que il a du mal il
pourquoi tu me regardes
donc on rencontre souvent avec de jeunes
actrices dans l'est dans les soirées
mondaines dans des collègues des caves
ou dans les premières semaines je
mentirais
votre épouse accepte ça très facilement
j'ai l'impression non elle est pour
mais elle sait que je reviendrai toute
façon et valorise à d'accord finalement
ça se passe bien c'est un couple moderne
je suis perdue mois là il ya un truc que
je comprends pas c'est cette passion des
clubs échangistes chevry je ne peux pas
aller dans un club échangiste on vous
voir comme l'a dit titoff la dernière
fois ouais c'est pour rencontrer des
animateurs télé face pour aborder la vie
dans la chambre des officiers
on a continué sur la vie privée dany
boon on va vous faire une carie au
mensonge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un truc que je comprends pas chez vous
c'est pourquoi cette envie comme ça que
vous avez absolument irrépressible de
sauter sur tout ce qui bouge c'est dû à
quoi c'est dû
oui parce que j'aime bien laisser tour
et tout ce qui bouge
quel que soit le même pas que des femmes
croient et c'est vrai et c'est depuis
tout petit comme c'est parce que j'ai
vécu je t'ai élevé avec un chien et un
mal
c'est beau très beau labrador de grande
taille
si c'est une liaison très très peu de
temps
durée et depuis je me manque c'est que
les filles les filles 6e soirée
n'étaient pas rassurés de savoir que
vous veniez valérie la maquilleuse la
dernière fois la wii elle voulait pas
aller où j'ai détruit à lui rendre
judith elle supporte comme ça que vous
la trompiez à tout bout de champ
elle accepte ça elle adore elle dit
vas-y continue ce formidable
ouais c'est là c'est un set à voix mais
elle doit en souffrir quand même non pas
du tout non non parce qu'elle fait
pareil vous avez un petit peu arrêter
les boîtes échangistes quand même non
j'ai arrêté
oui et non je vais je veux boire des
verres et puis des gens me touche faut
dire dany boon que vous avez un sexe
énorme tout petit minuscule ça c'est
très étonnant et je m'en suis rendu
compte bêtement on l'a dit
quelqu'un regardez mon sexe dans des
genres ou qu'est-ce que tu es loin et il
m'a vu à nantes est doublé à un moment
vous avez essayé de remplacer le sexe
par la drogue oui appris beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'erreurs il ya un
crochet énormément de cocaïne et là j'ai
complètement arrêté
ouais parce que je
parce que j'avais appelé la police quand
on dit leur venaient en croyant que
c'était de l'anthrax et
[Musique]
c'est du coup je me suis fait gauler
mais maintenant c'est des manques je je
prends de l'anthrax maintenant faut dire
qu'il vous faut beaucoup d'argent à dany
boon c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
dépensier je dépense a énormément de
l'argent des autres
ouais c'est ça le problème c'est que les
gens s'en rendent compte benoît 150
mètres carrés rue de la pompe
trois cent cinquante mille francs par
mois par jour 800 mètres carrés rue de
la pompe deux mercedes 600 oui j'en ai
fait ça mais je n'ai oui plusieurs
couleurs tout ça même et alors fait ce
piège de goût du luxe comme ça ça vous
avez deux assistants qui vous allumez
vos pétards faisait toute la journée
oui on assiste en toge qui font comme ça
avec des judith à cette baby sitter 7b
est là en un an après une huitième pour
s'occuper des sept autres une par jour
de la semaine c'est incroyable c'est
vrai avec qui je vais au club
d'échangistes pour boire des verres on
est d'un seul coup des gens nous touche
bel et bien des quand même puis des
trois mille balles au téléthon c'est
sympa j'ai appelé j'ai fait une promesse
et j'ai rien à voir
[Applaudissements]
ouais vous êtes du côté des possédants
maintenant un set dj berisha j'adore
j'adore 1
ah oui je connais des ministres et tout
ça hein
j'avais à droite maintenant c'est
franchement même limité sa droite
ouais bah oui votre rêve vous l'avez
déclaré votre rêve c'est un madelin qui
serait plus à droite ou un le pen plus
moderne plus moderne et mieux coiffée
[Rires]
plus personne ne veut vous donner son
numéro de portable non mais j'ai jeu par
contre leur prend leur portable à vais
pas changer un petit peu de latitude la
non vous aurez pas être un peu plus
sympathique avec les gens je t'emmerde
non je sais pas vous apprendre je suis
pas la solidarité la tolérance la
compassion sont pas des valeurs un peu
plus humaniste non mais gégé toutes ses
valeurs elle sent au bac en jeu quand je
croise quelqu'un je m'arrête maintenant
et si on vous croiser avec l'arrêt en
vous écrase vous êtes désormais comédien
c'est que la grande île et diani shoah
qui vous le dirai l'art de la comédie
c'est l'art de mentir
nous allons donc faire une interwiew
mensonge c'est très compliqué vous devez
répondre steevy exactement le contraire
de ce que vous pensez un acteur d'accord
il ya du piège oui je sors comment ça se
passe avec l'udc est plutôt très mal
vraiment très très mal c'est la cata que
les soirs bon il a compris le principe
pour déjà une chose reste on regarde ça
va tomber la map
stevie est ce que vous avez été obligé
de coucher pour avoir leur rôle
oui oui j'ai couché par hasard c'est
roland muzeau
avec ma main droite avec qui avec ma
main droite avec sa maman qui est des
monos sexuelle stevie ça vous fait quoi
que des gens payent plus de 40 euros
pour venir vous voir sur la scène d'un
théâtre ça je m'en contrefous vraiment
rien à [ __ ] chacun sa bourse
stevie imaginer qu'un jour vous marier
que vous ayez des enfants et que votre
fils viennent vous voir et vous annonce
qu'il est hétérosexuel vous réagiriez
comment très mal très mal
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait l'amour
et bourrique et stevie visite a fait
l'amour avec brit et enfin en tout cas
il est à côté de moi à michel demande
qui est bourriquet issue elle me
cherchez pas vous expliquer qu'ils aient
bourrique et alors bourrique et c'est
une petite tenue sur fond de grosses
menu ce que j'ai des plus l'âge de 6 ans
décidé au départ c'est marrant parce
qu'il est bien il est pratiquement plus
connu que moi vous riquez à chaque fois
peut-être pas des gens mais alors
comment va boudissa c'est là c'est le
truc voir comment on va vous sur
facebook et d'aborder bonheur stevie
avez-vous menti au cours de cette
interview
non le mystère c'est bien ça c'est une
interview beaucoup mieux poko vous fait
à chaque fois d'ailleurs parce que vous
êtes un grand menteur devant l'internet
d'une interview mensonge
gérard darmon vous êtes contents d'être
là je me sens un peu chez les messieurs
c'est sympa la promo c'est extrêmement
sympathique vous vous teniez les cheveux
là j'ai vu c'est pourquoi a alors c'est
quoi faire ses repères plus jeunes ou
pour faire plus vieux sénile omnium pour
montrer que j'ai des cheveux surtout que
vous vous trouvez comment physiquement
je me trouve extraordinairement beau
d'un charisme
[Musique]
qui dépassent l'entendement et d'une
intelligence nettement supérieur à la
moyenne
comme je suis en train de vous le
prouver depuis à peu près 20 minutes
alors concernant le sexe j'ai rarement
vous avez déclaré parce que bon on sait
que c'est un petit peu moins actif qu'à
une certaine époque
vous savez que l'interview mensonge j'ai
compris que c'est dans les yeux que ça
se passe oui c'est dans les yeux que ça
se passait pas plus beau l'amour
platonique
alors concernant la mort vous avez
déclaré j'aimerais mourir comme elvis
presley plein de tranquillisants et de
sucreries et non pas le contraire
voilà ce qui ne veut rien dire non plus
ça
edit ah tiens
qu'est-ce qu'il faut encore à ma télé
s
sur un audimat tu es plutôt bien monté
[Musique]
charlotte interview mensonges de
turckheim après vos premières
expériences enfantine aujourd'hui vous
avez des expériences homosexuelles de
façon très régulière très très très
régulière et oui les jours ah oui
toucher tous les jeux oui j'adore ça
dans les partouzes et plus du tout
coincé comme à l'agent n'est pas parce
que j'en organise maintenant j'en à
organiser ça chez moi
les pétards aussi il n'y a plus du tout
de problème comme la première fois vous
saviez pas ciblé de fumer ou pas oh ben
non parce que maintenant c'est pas
pareil maintenant on en plante dans le
jardin aussi si vous voulez donc je ne
sais pas un morceau avec manon on sait
pas trop ce qui s'est passé alors nous
on a un petit peu bosser vous travaillez
en fait là bas dans un bar sur les
ramblas
oui sinon je pars de nuit sur les
ramblas votre réputation vous le savez
là bas n'est plus à faire en vous
appelez lolo tu as le latin oui
absolument
ça va me dire un truc à bamako le lotois
à bar sur les ramblas je me souviens
plus que tu as fait l'adresse mais ce
mais c'est dans l'es6 et facile à
trouver
c'est dans le bas dans le bar la vuelta
c'est très très connu et personne ne le
sait ici safina mais non non non non non
il ya trois ans quand même un oui ça
durait trois ans et pourtant c'était un
bar magnifique accepté j'avoue plaisir
ah oui j'adorerais ça j'adore et oui le
vous étiez venus d'ailleurs vraiment
appeler charlotte sur l'ut à l'époque
c
le mieux alors voilà une histoire en
plus incroyable contrairement à ce que
tout le monde croit je tenais été refait
en fait je n'ai pas du tout années comme
ça au départ devient petit mais parisien
c'est bien j'avais années j'aurais
jamais rien donné que je trouvais ce
qu'ils voient là j'y suis j'y faisais
pas beaucoup et j'ai fait un coup bon ça
n'est pas ça n'a pas tout à fait réussi
à l'insa n'a pas tout à fait réussi mais
finalement vous regrettez pas d'avoir
fait refaire comme ça non certains
journaux ont écouté non cette année j'ai
faire les oreilles aussi parce
qu'évidemment je les trouve
mais je me demande s'il ne serait pas
mieux un peu plus comme ça de jouer
donne beaucoup tout ça également il ya
eu beaucoup d'histoires racontées sur
vos origines aristocratiques en fait
c'est pas vrai du tout cette année sur
l'autre
m oui tu devras schéma au huitième mais
arrêtez cours chez svp
ben là exactement j'habite à la
courneuve où je suis né le 4 juin
curiosity corse et se raconter des trucs
le premier rôle que joue et c'est au
café de la gare
j'ai joué le marchand de fromages dont
je parlais comme ça et le butin arrête
tu dégages et tous et j'étais plus jeune
et plus par année un agent qui m'a dit
en fait je voulais publicité attend le
pseudo tu t'es pris c'est absolument
génial j'ai dit commencer à medibat
s'appelait anne charlotte de turckheim
c'est quand même c'est quand même gros
que je pensais que c'était un pseudo
sur un peu
et on va faire une cave you man sens
[Musique]
le principe les simples steevy doit
répondre en mentant rayhana pour qu'il
se serait pas difficile ici bien sûr un
mais pour vous c'est un petit peu
compliqué mais vous êtes tellement puant
mon petit cochon si vite ça se passe
comment avec le pied très très mal est
fait souffrir
donc ça veut dire que ça va très bien
voilà tu as choisi pourquoi alors ok
pour mon corps à 6 lors qui tu aimes son
humour ou alors là pas dit cela je crois
que c'est pas un monstre et dis-moi
steevy tu crois que tu auras un molière
un jour oui je pense ouais tu sais qui
c'est molière bien sûr pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
j'y vis tu sais qu'il ya beaucoup de
rumeurs ont couru sur toi non à 6-6 oui
non mais si un jour ton fils tu annoncé
qu'il est hétérosexuel tu réagirais
comment j'aurais pas de fils stevie tu
m'aimes pas du tout
st
m
c'est ce qu'on va faire si j'ai menti on
va lui faire une interview mensonge
intervenants
[Musique]
luis fernandez se mettre très facile
pour vous il suffit de mentir et je
pense que quand on a été entraîneur du
psg c'est pas difficile
d'accord depuis que vous êtes partie le
psg a gagné la coupe de france et a fait
deuxième du championnat est ce que ça
vous fait plaisir louise de voir ses
résultats
oui vous l'avez trouvé comment le jeu du
psg cette année
très bon avec vous à la tête de l'équipe
est ce que le psg aurait fait mieux
non vous êtes malheureux d'avoir dû
quitter paris luis oui vous pensez quoi
de votre successeur tout devient que du
bien c'est mon docteur ah oui c'est vrai
qu'au psg il ya plus d'entraîneuse que
d'entraîneur oui est-ce que d'après vous
le psg peut être champion de france l'an
prochain
non quand vous avez annoncé au jdd que
vous aviez un plan pour reprendre le psg
c'est un mensonge
non oui vous raconter beaucoup de
conneries quand même ça m'arrive souvent
mais là tu mens pas vous vous sentez
responsable de l'échec avec ronaldinho
oui vous n'avez jamais eu envie de vous
excuser auprès des supporters du psg
oui bon c'est quoi des fachos du parc
sens un pareil sans ça c'est des bons
joueurs mais ça vous dirait un jour de
devenir entraîneur l'équipe de france
oui notre défi c'est de retourner au
parc des princes pour chanter non vous
êtes content d'être venu ce soir
non non voilées ne va pas on va pas
revenir comme dans chaque émission de
télévision sur vos exploits conjugaux et
extra conjugaux parce que ça a déjà été
beaucoup fait dis moi je préfère je
préfère en vous l'artiste que le que le
mari me suis heureux j'ai quatre femmes
je suis heureux j'ai trois petits
branchages et la maman belge et les
quatre pays les trois petits bouts de
choux et la maman quand même mais je
suis un papa heureux
rama yade
on va faire une interview mensonge alors
vous savez comment c'est l'interview
mensonge vous répondais linverse de la
vérité vous montez khaled interview m'en
sens alors khaled comment ça va pas bien
vous êtes content d'être ici ce soir
non ça vous fait quel âge maintenant 11
ans ça brille et je les avais 11 ans
parce que je le dis parce que cette
année cgc s'étaient mal et en 2012 avait
eu 10 ans voilà est-ce que c'est vrai
khaled que vous porter la moustache en
hommage à francis cabrel
oui ou à saddam hussein oui c'est vrai
que vous avez vous tendre en blonde
oui vous avez grossi la non un petit peu
c'est vrai que vous êtes mis à manger du
porc maintenant oui grave c'est surtout
le marcassin inquiet du bacon d'un club
sans le médecin
la date un cutter à l'aide
vous allez arrêter de boire non
définitivement
ça fait huit ans maintenant 8 ans vous
avez arrêté votre dernière quit c'était
al 2 3 soleil met d'accord
voila voila c'est que c'est l'interview
mensonge là non je vois toujours et
encore moi pas de vols je pense qu'il ya
pas de mal à se faire plaisir si le
fruit du dur alors va t il et comment
votre nouveau disque là n'est pas venir
du tout les années de pierre dutot vous
pensez être le meilleur chanteur de raï
du monde aujourd'hui
non
alors vous êtes fans de jenifer de la
star ac voulait mais beaucoup vous avez
tous ses disques d'or grave
cheb mami vous l'aimez bien mon dieu que
je la donne et faudel vous le trouvez
comment va pas bien pas bien du tout pas
bien du tout marc olivier fogiel vous
l'aimez bien à lui je le kiffe grave le
sénat ben alouane la télévision vous
préférez son émission la mienne son
édition vous êtes heureux aujourd'hui
radel non c'est vrai que c'est un grand
buteur
oui vous aimez votre femme radel non
vous l'avait déjà trompée plusieurs fois
plusieurs fois vous êtes quand on est
venu ce soir là non
vous allez mentir là vous avez menti
dans sa vallée nul n'en sait plus à quoi
ton et non pas par la santé le reste
c'est comme fred astaire et ginger
rogers quoi c'est quand vous êtes
obligés de vous retrouver ces mêmes et
on fait ça pour l'argent
ouais ça vous plaît de faire la promo
saad et moi j'aime pas du tout veut rien
dire c'est moi ça me fait ça m'embête un
peu parfois ça dépend ouais il est bien
ce dvd l'intégrale de l'ain c'est une
merde comment ta question va être montée
mais c'est une épreuve qu'il faut
l'acheter pour noël ce qui rend banon
non tas d'autres trucs à acheter un
achète le dvd de là à dire des conneries
comme ça on risque de vraiment unique et
la promo je vous le dis mais c'est bien
continuez
oui mais oui mais il peut dire aussitôt
met à poil se mettra pas les seuils
voilà jamais je me met à poil moi mais
ça n'aura pas coupé
j'adore laurent gerra
[Musique]
faire une interview mensonge tu connais
tu veux le principe doit mentir voilà
c'est pas compliqué comment ça va co et
bah écoute ça va super bien
ouais t'es content d'être ici ce soir
franchement je me fais chier grave et ça
me saoule j'aime ça cette séquelle âge
maintenant écoute un bon 22 ouais là les
volets demain tagro si un peu non
d'abord ça me fait très plaisir ce que
tu me dis et non je pense que j'ai pas
mal mais grid 1 ou 2 kg 1
ouais tu dois beaucoup à bataille et
fontaine que dalle je trouve que ce sont
des gros cons tu es fier de travailler
avec eux écoute je vomis chaque matin
mais beaucoup moins je suis beaucoup
beaucoup tu arriveras pas me faire dire
des saloperies que tf1 ça se passe bien
écoutons se défoncer la gueule tous les
matins tous les matins on s'insultait
tout avec les patrons de tf1 c'est une
affaire d'amitié avant tout non non
c'est une affaire de coucheries c'est
parce que je suis le fils d diène et il
ya eu des rapports plus haut entre nous
la méthode cauet tu trouve ça original
comme concept déhanché ans je trouve que
je t'ai tour pompe et ça c'est pas
l'interview moins 100 mais si non tu as
ton carnet de chèques d'écrire je vais
demander d'ailleurs il m'a doublé pour
les actuels philippe l'écoutera parce
que je voudrais devenir le reste du
décor est la mienne vous pouvez la fin
de l'année je te donne face à des
poulets colonnes j'avais les colonnes
corinthiennes j'appelle ça des poutres
foot
il aplatit
et la belette insu un but en 10 mois il
ya comme des interviews un peu qui
ressemble un peu à celle de tout le
monde en parle des fois écoute
franchement non jamais oh oui je suis
très content j'invente 1 je n'arrive
même pas à le suivre mais tu comprends
bien c'est lui le meilleur animateur de
la tête après quand je suis mauvais bond
des prix il est édenté starting blocks
les griffes ne commet jamais une
interview qui ressemble aux miennes
débat rien tu as remarqué je n'ai jamais
fait de scandale à toi suite envoyé une
lettre où une fois mais après j'ai
abandonné oui mais j'avais tout mis
dedans tu as les 1er 2 avec matador et
il avait dit que je gère pompe et est
auteur et qui avait des trucs dans ton
émission qui était dans la mienne voilà
c'est plutôt des trucs dans ton émission
culte mais j'ai pas j'ai pas su quoi
répondre et d'ailleurs ce que je
comprends bien non même envoyé un chèque
je n'ai pas ce que parce que d'abord tu
as peut-être paf tu as peut-être pas
tort vu que tu fais de la tna mais tant
que tu fais de la télé depuis avant moi
vu que georgette pas cité de date mais
vu que quand j'étais petit je regardais
mes quinze jours iman que j'étais fan
jamais je ne manque plus que j'étais fan
de lunettes pas pour nuits blanches que
j'aimais double jeu revient à l'antenne
on voit bien qu'on n'a pas été nombreux
à aimer mais moi j'aime et et les zèbres
ou alors il ya un truc que je comprends
pas a me dit tu étais de chez daphné
roulier tu m'as pas cité une seule fois
et ta chemise jaune pour il pas ce cas
ci je si c'est parce que si je cite tout
le monde ça fait lèche cul donc parce
que j'ai cités qui j'ai cité foucault un
statut et admirait beaucoup déjà et a
trompé la patrie chambéry guerre mais
mais pourquoi revenir sébastien mais en
plus tu sais que tu me pique mes idées
mais j'existe mais je te piquent pas tes
idées je trouve juste que je franchement
je vous jure que c'est vrai c'est un
hommage
franchement quand on fait un hommage
chaque semaine à tyr ardisson non mais
franchement stupide tous je n'ai pas
répondu à ta lettre mais je te jure
qu'on t'a rien impliqué d'accord et je
te promets que si j'enlève le manceau là
je te les rendrait ici je te les amène
ch'ur d'accord fait le studio de la
méthode cauet je te prends le pari si je
viens tu as mené les colonnes donc on
enlève derrière mais parce que moi perso
j'en peux plus si toi j'aime bien vos
cheveux blonds j'adore donc je te les
ramène riche d'imagés quelles sont les
émissions que tu regardes en ce moment
pas beaucoup je dois te regarde et toi
c'est obligé en même temps non assise
pour trouver des idées non non ouais il
paraît que tu es un grand b heures c'est
vrai écoute non
[Musique]